if you get an email or a message from
lex friedman
saying how much
i lex you know appreciate you and love
you and so on and please connect with me
on my whatsapp number and i will give
you bitcoin or something like that
please do not click
and i
i'm aware that there's a lot of this
going on a very large amount i can't do
anything about it this is on every
single platform it's happening more and
more and more
uh which i've been recently
informed that they're not emailing so
it's cross-platform
they're taking people's they're somehow
this is fascinating to me because
they are
taking people who comment on various
social platforms
and they somehow reverse engineer they
figure out what their email is and they
send an email to that person
saying from lex friedman and it's like a
heartfelt email with links
it's fascinating because it's
cross-platform now it's not just a spam
bot that's messaging us and a comment
that in a reply
they are saying okay this person cares
about this other person on social media
so i'm going to find another channel
which in their mind probably increases
and then does the likelihood that
they'll get uh the people to click
and they do i don't know what to do
about that it makes me really really sad
especially with podcasting there's an
intimacy
that people feel connected and they get
really excited okay cool let's i want to
talk to lex
and they click
and
like i
i get angry at the people that do this i
mean you're um
it's like the john that gets hired uh
the fake employee i mean i don't know
what to do about that i mean i suppose
that's the i suppose the solution is
education
it's uh telling people to be skeptical
on stuff they click
uh it's it that's that balance with the
technology solution of creating a um
maybe like two-factor authentication and
um
maybe helping identify things that are
likely to be spam i don't know
but then the machine learning there is
tricky because you don't want to add a
lot of extra friction
that just annoys people because they'll
turn it off because you have the accept
cookies thing right
that everybody has to click on now so
now they completely ignore they accept
cookies this is very difficult
to find that frictionless security
you